[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف قال اكثم بن صيفي صاحب المعروف
لا يقع واذا وقع وجد متكئا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى وما خلقت الجن والانس الا
ليعبدون
واصله كلمه جن يعود الى الاستتار جاء في
لسان العرب جن الشيطان
في بطن امه
لو تعلمين بما اجينا من الهوى لعذرت اولا
ظلمت ان لم تعدل لو تعلمين بما اجينا من
الهوى بما اخفي من الاشياء
[موسيقى]
اسحاق القيرواني في كتابه زهر الالباب ان
الحسن ابن سهل قال لسالم الحراري ما
المنزله التي اذا نزل بها الكاتب كان
كاتبا في قوله وفعله
واستحقاقه فقال ان يكون مطبوعا على
المعرفه محتنيكا بالتجربه عارفا بحلال
الكتاب وحرامه وبالدهور في تصرفها
واحكامها وبالملوك في سيرها وايامها
واجناس الخط وباديه الاقلام مع تشكل اللفظ
وقرب الماخذ قال الحسن فليس في الدنيا اذا
انك كاتب
تعرفون لماذا لان من الف قد استهدف ومن
كتب فقد عرض فكره على الناس وصار عرضه
لسهام النقد والتشكيك فكيف لا يكون حاضر
البديع جاهزا للوقوف دون رايه وقلمه وكيف
يتاثى له ذلك من دون اسباب المعرفه ومن
دون ما تقدم ذكره في قول الرجل
[موسيقى]
مستعمل والسكينه في مطابخنا يوميا وهي
المديه كما عرفها لسان العرب واصله
تسميتها 60 انها تسكن الذبيحه ورد في
جمهره اللغه السكين عربي معروف وهو فعيل
من قولهم ذبحت الشيء حتى سكن اضطرابه
حاولت ان اذكر بيت من الشعر فيه كلمه سكين
لكن لم تسعف من الذاكره فاذا ذكرتم شيئا
فاكتبوه لنا في تعليقاتكم
[موسيقى]
كان لرجل من الاعراب النحويين ولد اسمه
حمزه فبينما حمزه يمشي مع ابيه اذ برجلا
يصيح بشهاب يا عبد الله فلم يجبه ذلك
الشاب فقال الرجل منتهرا الا تسمع فقال
الشاب يا عم كلنا عبيد الله اي عبد الله
تعني
التفت النحوي الى ولده وقال يا حمزه الا
ترى بلاغه هذا الشاب لما كان من الغد اذا
برجل ينادي شابا يا حمزه فقال له حمزه ولد
نحوي يا عم كلنا حماميد الله
فهي حمزه
فقال له ابوه ليس يعنيك يا من احمد الله
به ذكر ابيه
[موسيقى]
العرب تفننوا في مدح المراه وفي وصفها
ابدا في وصف العيون
والجيد والشعر والجسد ولم يتركوا شيئا
بالشكل الا واورده في اشعارهم ولكن ماذا
عن المضمون ماذا عن الاخلاق ماذا عن العقل
وهو يقول ليست بفاحشه في بيت جارتها ولا
تعاب ولا ترمى بها الريب ان جاء ورتهن لم
ياخذن شيمتها وان مشينا بها لم تدري من
الغضب
واسمع الى ابن زيدون حين يقول لولاده كانك
ناظرت اهل الكلام واتيت فهما بعلم الجدل
كما اجمل ان يوافق جمالها
[موسيقى]
قالوا من تطبع بطباع غيره نزعته العاده
حتى ترده الى طبعه كما ان الماء اذا
اسخنته وتركته ساعه عاد الى طبعه من
الوروده
والشجره المره لو طليتها بالعسل لا تثمر
الا مره وفي هذا يقول المتنبي ابا خلق
الدنيا حبيبي
كما طلبي منها حبيبا ترده واسرع مفعول فعل
تتغير
ومثل ذلك قول الاعور الشمي
ومن يقترف خلقا وخلق نفسه يدعه وتغلبه
وعليه الطبائع وادوام اخلاق الفتى ما مشى
به واقصر افعال الرجال البدائع
يقول المتنبي
ولنفس اخلاق تدل على الفتى
اكان سخاء ما اتى ان تساخيرا
[موسيقى]
اذا كنت تقصد اسم المره من قضاء الحج فهي
الحاجه بفتح الحاء اما اذا اردت الدليل
والبرهان فقل الحجه بضم الحاء واذا قلت
الحجه بكسر الحاء وجمعها حجاج فانت تشير
الى السنه يقول الله تعالى على ان تاجرني
ثماني حجج اي 8 سنوات
قال تعد الاتصالات الفضائيه اليوم من
الامور الاساسيه في حياتنا ولكن لا تقل
تعتبر
الاتصالات من الامور الاساسيه فعل اعتبره
يعني اخذ العبره والتعاضه
تعجب ورد في لسان العرب اعتبر منه اي تعجب
منه وفي التنزيل يقول تعالى فاعتبروا يا
اولي الابصار اي تدبروا وانظروا وفي
القاموس اعتبر منه تعجب والعبر
او تردد البكاء في الصدر او الحزن بلا
بكاء لكن اعتذر عموما لم ترد بمعنى عده
لذلك قل تعد الاشياء كذا ولا تقلت تعتبر
الاشياء
[موسيقى]
العامه تقول وشوشني في اذني بمعنى همس لي
وهذه الكلمه اصيله نصيحه ورد في القاموس
المحيط توشوش اي تحركوا وهمس بعضهم الى
بعض
وجاء في اللسان ان الوشوشه كلام مختلط حتى
لا يكاد يفهم واما التشويش فقال ابو منصور
انه لا اصل له في العربيه وانه من كلام
المولدين واصله التهويش بمعنى التخليط
بعض اهلنا في قبائل الجزيره العربيه اليوم
يستخدمون
الوشوشه بمعنى او يضعونها في معنى الكشكشه
الكشكشه تلك الظاهره اللغويه التي تنقلب
فيها الكاف المؤنثه الى شين ابدا من ان
تقول لها كيف حالك تقول كيف حالك شلونك
وكيف اخبارك هذه هي يسمونها الوشوش
يقول المثل جاورينا واخبرينا كما قصته هذا
المثل يضرب المثل للدلاله على الغش الذي
قد تبديه المظاهر وعلى ان الجمال كامل في
النفوس خالد فيها بينما جمال الشكل خداع
مؤقت اما قصه المثل فتحكي عن رجلين تعلق
بامراه وتوددها
اوله ما كان بهي الطلعه حسن المنظر وكان
يقول لها عاشرين وانظري الينا واما الثاني
فكان دميما تقتحمه العين وكان يكرر على
مسامعها جاورينا واخبرينا طبعا المراه
بطبيعه الحال كانت مياله الى الحسن المليح
لكن اصرار الشخص الاخر وجملته الدائمه
اثراء فضلها تقررت ان تختبر الامر وطلبت
من كل منهما ان يذبح ناقه لحين قدومها
ثم تذكره فيزي رفض اظهرها عجوزا مسكينه و
ذهبت اليهما فلما دخلت على الوسيم وجدته
عند القدر يلحس الدسم وياكل الشحم سالته
شيئا من اللحم فاعطاها ارض الطعام ثم
اتجهت الى بيت الدميم فاذا هو يقسم لحم
الجزور ويعطي كل من ساله طلبت منه ان
يعطيها شيئا تختصها لاطيب قطعه في الناقه
وارسل معها من يحمل اللحمه خوفا عليها من
التعب في الصباح زارها الرجلان فكشفت لهما
عن قصتها معهما وانكرت على الوسيم فعله
واختارت الكريم زوجا لها بعد ان جاء ورثه
وخبرته
جاورينا واخبرينا يضرب في الشيء الذي يكون
قبيح المنظر ولكنه جميل لخضر يقول الشاعر
ترى الرجل النحيل فتزدريه وفي اثوابه اسد
عصور ويعجبك الطريق الى تراه فيخلف ظن ذكر
رجل غريب
[موسيقى]
اذا سالتكم في تويتر عن بيت من الشعر فيه
اسم شخص تحبونه
معكم بعض ما وصلني من مشاركاتكم
مشاركه من حمد
يقول
يا ليل كم من حاجه لمهمه اذا جئتك بالليل
لم ادري ما هي طبعا يتبادل الى ذهن المراه
انه يقصد ليله لكن وضع ملاحظه بين قوسين
يقول ليست ليله بل هي هيا لكن يا احمد هذه
هي بكسر الهوى
الاديبه سعديه مفرح شاركتنا في هذا الوسم
واا مرحبا بها طبعا يقول احسب اعمار الدار
يا سعود جدران واثرها مال الدار يا سعود
اهلها بيت من الشعر عند البطيء والمقصود
كما هو واضح
هو سعود
محمد يقول فاطمه مهلا بعض هذا التدللي
طبعا البيت معروف
والسالب يقول
قالوا كده مبسم هيا قلت لا لا بين البروق
وبين مبسم يا فرق
القصيده معروفه عند اهل الشعر النبطي
يعرفها كثيرون
للشاعر الراحل محسن الهزاني عليه رحمه
الله وهي من عيون الشعر النبطي
مشاركه نبطيه اخرى من شيخه تقول وضحى لها
من طعم الغيم طله تسجيل كبود بلطفها مثل
الازهار
ومشاركه من ايهاب يقول وان ضاقت بك الايام
صبرا ستولد بعد صبرك 1000 بشرى
السلام يقول سلام
سلام لا ادري اذا كان رجلا او امراه لكن
واضح انه يقصد نفسه ويضيف ابيات النبطيه
ايضا يقول انا ولد عم المطاليق يا سعود
ماني غريب يعد نفسهم حايدا رحتي يفقدني
هالطيب والجود وان جيت يا فرح البنايم
سعود له نصيب جيد اليوم مشاركاتكم
ريم تقول ريم على القاعده
وسميه تقول يحضرني قول الشاعر الجاهلي
الغطمش الضبي ابلغ سميه اني لست ناسيها
عمري ولا قاضي من حبها عادي
الله الله
ومشاركه من ابو سعود يقول وما فقد الماضون
مثل محمد ولا مثله حتى القيامه يفقد
اللهم صل على محمد
اذا
هذا البيت
المشاركات
اشكركم جزيل الشكر على تفاعلكم في فقره
وسم
وذكركم بانتظره تاملات الجزيره عند نهايه
كل مشاركه
هذا صاحب المنار والمنار قبل ان تظهر
المنتديات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي باكثر
من 100 سنه كانت تشكل منتدى كانت تويتر في
زمن لم يكن في تويتر
الثقافيه الاجتماعيه الدينيه
العلميه الفقهيه
ويقرؤون اجاباتها في الاعداد اللاحقه
كانت معلمه بمعنى الكلمه اليوم احدثكم عن
صاحب المنار محمد رشيد رضا
كتب عنه الامام محمد عبده ان الله بعث لي
بهذا الشاب ليكون مددا لحياتي ومزيدا في
عمري
وقد ابتليت بما يشغلني عنها وهو يقوم
ببيانها الان كما اعتقد واريد
الامام محمد رشيد بن علي رضا الموجود في
قريه القلمون شمال لبنان في سنه 65
و8000 لاسره شريفه من العطره النبويه
الشريفه تتصل بالنسب لال الحسين بن علي
رضي الله عنهما
تلقى اولى علومه على يدي والده الشيخ علي
رضا امام مسجد القلمون فحفظ القران وتعلم
مبادئ القراءه والكتابه والحساب
وتوسعت علومه في النحو والصرف والعلوم
العربيه والشرعيه والمنطقه الرياضيه
والفلسفه الطبيعيه وذلك في مدارس الشمال
هناك توطدت علاقته بالشيخ حسين الجسر وهو
مدير احدى المدارس ومن رواد النهضه
الثقافيه العربيه
الشيخ الجسر اعجبا بالشهاب النبي محمد
رشيد رضا فضله الى حلقات دروسه ثم اجازه
بتدريس العلوم الشرعيه
والعقليه والعربيه تنهمك محمد رشيد الشاب
بالتدريس وبالدرس على ايدي علماء طرابلس
مثل الشيخ عبد الغني الرافعي محمد القاضي
ومحمد الحسين وغيرهم
في تلك الفتره كان الشيخ محمد عبده منفيا
من مصر الى بيروت حيث القادر روسيا في
التربيه والتعليم
وكان محمد رشيد شديد الاعجاب بافكار محمد
عبده الاصلاحيه التقى به مرتين حين زار
الشيخ طرابلس وتوثقت الصلاه بين الرجلين
لا سيما ان محمد رشيد رضا كان يرى في
الشيخ محمد عبده الخلف الصالح لجمال الدين
الافغاني في ميدان الاصلاح وايقاظ الشرق
من سباته
كانت
لافغاني طبعا موده وحضور في قلب محمد رشيد
رضا اسمع ما قاله عن كتاب العروه الوثقى
للافباني
ثم اني رايت في محفوظات والدي بعض نسخ
العروه الوثقى فكان كل منها كسلك من
الكهرباء اتصل بي باحدث في نفسي من الهزه
والانفعال والحراره والاشتعال ما قذف بي
من طور الى طور ومن حال الى حال
شعر محمد رشيد رضا ان لبنان مساحه ضيقه
للعمل في مجال اصلاح الامه اشد العزم الى
مصر في عام 98
و8000 واتصل بالامام محمد عبده الذي كان
قد سبقه في العوده وجرى الاتفاق بينهما
على اختيار الصحافه ميدانا للعمل الاصلاحي
فولدت مجله المنار التي هدفت الى الاصلاح
الديني والاجتماعي للامه وانتشرت بشكل
كبير بين الناس وعرف محمد رشيد رضا باسم
صاحب المنار
على الرغم من كونه محرر المجله الرئيسي
كتب مئات المقالات والدراسات في المجله
تركز معظمها على وسائل النهوض بالامه
وتقويتها
وتوجيه العلماء والحكام لانهم العقل
المدبر والروح المفكر
اذا رايت الكذب والزور والرياء والنفاق
والحقد والحسد
واشباهها من الرذائل فاشيه في امه تحكم
على امرائها وحكامها بالظلم والاستبداد
على علمائها ومرشديها بالبدايه والفساد
والعكس بالعكس
كم اهتم صاحبنا بوحده اهل الاسلام في
الارض اقترح تاليف كتاب يضم ما اتفقت عليه
الفرق الاسلاميه المختلفه خصوصا في
المسائل التي تنعكس في المجتمع كالاخلاق
وتهذيب النفس والعمل الحسن وكان طموحه ان
تنتشر نسخ من هذا الكتاب في اسقاء العالم
الاسلامي ما يحس المسلمين على التيقد من
انما يجمعهم اكبر بكثير مما يفرقهم
كما خصص الكثير من جهده للتربيه والتعليم
فمذهبه يتلخص بان سعاده الامم باعمالها
وكمال اعمالها من وطن بانتشار العلوم
والمعارف فيها وقد عمل على انشاء مدرسه
دار الدعوه والارشاد لتخريج الدعاه من
انحاء العالم الاسلامي لكن قله التمويل
والدلاع الحرب العالميه
واداه هذا المشروع الطموح بعد سنتين من
انشاءه
ترك الشيخ محمد رشيد رضا مؤلفات عديده الى
جانب مقالاته وابحاثه الغزيره في مجله
المنار من مؤلفاته تفسير المنار الذي
استكمل فيه ما بداه شيخه محمد عبده
توفي الشيخ محمد رشيد رضا في مصر في عام
وما زالت المعلمه المنار حيه الى يوم
ناسها
[موسيقى]
شيء من لزوم مالا يلزم في هذه الابيات
لذو مالا يلزم هو ان تاتي بالقافيه
تجيء باكبر عدد ممكن من الاحرف المتشابهه
في القوافي بداخل القصيده فمثلا اذا كانت
القافيه الاولى عيدكم بامكانك ان تاتي في
القافيه الثانيه مثلا واريدكم غيدكم لكن
اسرارك على ان تاتي بالعين والياء والدال
والكاف والميم كلها في كامل القوافي هذا
ما نسميه لزوم ما لا يلزم
اقول في ذلك
ستثمر اغصان المحبه بينكم ويقطف منها
جاركم
وبعيدكم
قضى الله ان الحق يعرف اهله اقول لاهل
الظلم هذا وعيدكم ولا تحزنوا من جوع يوم
مفارق فمن بعد شهر الصوم يشرق عيدكم
وكونوا لهذه الارض مسكن وعنبرا فمنها
خلقناكم وفيها نعيدكم السلام
[موسيقى]